Hello, beautiful nerds. I am so excited about our new miniseries Hidden Levels. It's a six-part show about how video games left the arcade and started reshaping the real world. We made it in partnership with WBUR's Endless Thread, and it's co-hosted and created by Ben Brock Johnson. The show launches wide on both the 99PI and Endless Thread feeds on Tuesday, October 7th. But if you're already a serious XM podcast plus subscriber, the first two episodes, are already waiting for you right now. Ben and I wanted to get the word out about the show
你好，各位可爱的极客们。我非常兴奋地向大家介绍我们的新迷你剧《隐藏关卡》（Hidden Levels）。这是一档六集节目，讲述了电子游戏如何走出游戏厅并开始重塑现实世界。我们与 WBUR 的《无尽线索》（Endless Thread）合作制作了这档节目，并由本·布洛克·约翰逊（Ben Brock Johnson）共同主持和创作。该节目将于 10 月 7 日星期二在 99PI 和《无尽线索》的订阅源中全面上线。但如果你已经是 SiriusXM 播客的付费订阅用户，前两集现在就已经在等着你了。本和我希望能让大家知道这个节目
to video gamers everywhere. So we went on the great Get Played podcast to talk with hosts Heather Ann Campbell and Matt Appadaca. And it was such a great conversation and they were such gracious hosts that we wanted to share that conversation with 99PI listeners. You'll hear about how Ben came up with the idea for the series and a sneak peek at some of the things that we'll be covering. And as the kids say, a whole lot of new Roman Mars lore gets dropped. So if you're ever curious about what I was doing from around 1997 to 1999 and what it has to do with video games stay tuned all right well Heather why don't we introduce our guests okay Matt let's do it okay from the podcast 99% Invisible and WBUR and their new series
传达给各地的游戏玩家。所以我们参加了很棒的《Get Played》播客，与主持人希瑟·安·坎贝尔（Heather Ann Campbell）和马特·阿帕达卡（Matt Appadaca）进行了交谈。这是一次非常棒的对话，他们也是非常亲切的主人，所以我们想与 99PI 的听众分享这次对话。你将听到本是如何构思这个系列节目的，以及我们将要涵盖的一些内容的预告。正如孩子们所说，会有很多关于罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）的新背景故事被揭露。所以，如果你一直好奇我在 1997 年到 1999 年左右在做什么，以及它与电子游戏有什么关系，请保持关注。好了，希瑟，我们来介绍一下我们的嘉宾吧。好的，马特，我们开始吧。好的，来自播客《99% 隐形》（99% Invisible）和 WBUR，以及他们的新系列
Hidden Levels what could that be about well I'll tell you it explores the impact of video games on modern culture it's Roman Mars and Ben Brock Johnson what's up guys hi guys Hey, hey, nice to see y'all. Welcome. Welcome to Get Played the show. This is like we're actually doing the show in a very serious way now. We sound so professional and normally none of this tone is present. No, no. Everyone is like, this is false. Yeah. This is not true. There's an artifice here. Matt and Heather have been replaced with AI. Yeah. They've got like just avatars doing the show.
《隐藏关卡》，那会是什么内容呢？嗯，我来告诉你，它探讨了电子游戏对现代文化的影响。这是罗曼·马斯和本·布洛克·约翰逊。大家好。嗨，伙计们。嘿，嘿，很高兴见到你们。欢迎。欢迎来到《Get Played》节目。这感觉就像我们现在真的在以一种非常严肃的方式做节目。我们听起来太专业了，通常这种语气是不存在的。不，不。每个人都会说，这是假的。是的。这不是真的。这里有一种虚假感。马特和希瑟已经被人工智能取代了。是的。他们就像是有化身在做节目。
I was just sitting with my fingers like laced. Yeah. In the hand. Little Gendo from Evangelian. Yeah, I was being Gendo from Evangelian. Get in the robot. Roman, get in the robot. Thanks for being here, you guys. So you guys have a new podcast series that's coming out. You said the street date was October 7th.
我刚才只是把手指交叉在一起。是的。放在手里。就像《新世纪福音战士》里的源堂。是的，我刚才在模仿《新世纪福音战士》里的源堂。驾驶机器人吧。罗曼，驾驶机器人吧。谢谢你们来到这里。所以你们有一个即将推出的新播客系列。你们说发布日期是 10 月 7 日。
Why don't you tell us a little bit about Hidden Levels? Go for it, Ben. All right. Well, Hidden Levels is something that I started talking to Roman and his team about about a year ago. Wow. And it came out of this thing that I was, seeing, and look, this is going to be a statement of the obvious for you in your audience, right? Like, video games impact the world beyond video games.
你们为什么不给我们介绍一下《隐藏关卡》呢？开始吧，本。好的，嗯，《隐藏关卡》是我大约一年前开始与罗曼和他的团队讨论的事情。哇。它源于我所看到的一些东西，听着，这对你和你的听众来说可能显而易见，对吧？就像，电子游戏对游戏之外的世界产生了影响。
Hell, yeah. And I think it's one of those things that people who are in gaming and who play video games, they know. They see it all the time as they walk through the world. They see things that they recognize as coming from their culture and the world that they inhabit when they play games. But I think a lot of people who don't know video gaming as well or don't play games don't see that stuff and don't recognize it as easily.
当然。我认为这是那些身处游戏圈并玩电子游戏的人所知道的事情之一。当他们走在世界上时，他们总是能看到这一点。他们看到的东西，他们认出是来自他们的文化，以及他们玩游戏时所居住的世界。但我认为很多不太了解电子游戏或不玩游戏的人看不到这些东西，也不会那么容易认出它们。
And, you know, I've always been a huge fan of Roman show. I make a show about the internet called Endless Thread for WBUR, this public radio station in Boston, and always been a huge fan of Roman's show. And Roman show, which Roman will introduce better than me, is all about the, you know, the architecture and design in the world that you don't see, but is hugely important and has an impact beyond its creators. So it just kind of felt like a match made in a video game dungeon, and we went from there. It's neat to hear you say that, like, video games have become sort of like ubiquitously infused into culture because there was a time in certainly our lifetimes when that wasn't the case. And now you will see video game language on like a billboard. You'll see things that say like level up your workout. And leveling up was once a thing that was in an instruction booklet for Super Mario Brothers.
而且，你知道，我一直是罗曼节目的超级粉丝。我为波士顿的公共广播电台 WBUR 制作了一个关于互联网的节目，叫《无尽线索》，我一直是罗曼节目的超级粉丝。而罗曼的节目——罗曼会比我介绍得更好——完全是关于你看不见的建筑和设计，但它们非常重要，并且对创作者之外产生了影响。所以这感觉就像是在游戏地下城中天作之合，我们就从那里开始了。听到你这么说真好，电子游戏已经变得像无处不在地融入了文化，因为在我们的有生之年，肯定有一段时间并非如此。现在你会在广告牌上看到电子游戏语言。你会看到像“提升你的锻炼水平”（level up your workout）这样的词。而“升级”（leveling up）曾经只是《超级马里奥兄弟》说明书里的东西。
Like you would have to be like, you'd have to learn the vocabulary and then understand it on your television and tell your friends at recess. And now these are just, they're sort of like permafrost on reality now. Yeah. I mean, they're really, they're almost mundane in every day is part of the thing. They're not like notable. And that's sort of what, that's sort of the bailiwick of 99% invisible. It's about, you know, the design that is part of the built world that becomes so. ordinary doorknobs, sewer covers, you know, like, you know, and, and all of a sudden, like,
就像你必须学习词汇，然后在电视上理解它，并在课间休息时告诉你的朋友。而现在这些就像是现实中的永久冻土。是的。我的意思是，它们在日常生活中几乎是平凡的，这是其中的一部分。它们并不引人注目。这正是《99% 隐形》的领域。它是关于建筑世界中变得如此平凡的设计，门把手、下水道盖子，你知道，突然之间，
looking at them deeply and going, oh, there's a story in that. Like, somebody made that a decision there and they designed something and we're interacting with it every day. And video games are just ripe for this because the way that they've infiltrated, you know, real life and back and forth and they communicate. And it's just, it's huge and it's rich. And we had, you know, we have six stories in this series. But there's like, hundreds more, like we could possibly do. Yeah, I guess so there's, it's a six episode mini series, right? And so six different stories, do they all sort of like follow like a similar trajectory?
深入观察它们，然后说，哦，里面有一个故事。就像，有人在那里做了一个决定，他们设计了一些东西，我们每天都在与它互动。而电子游戏正适合这一点，因为它们渗透到现实生活中的方式，以及它们来回沟通的方式。这太巨大且丰富了。我们在这个系列中有六个故事。但还有成百上千个，我们可能可以做。是的，我想是的，这是一个六集的迷你剧，对吧？所以六个不同的故事，它们是否都遵循类似的轨迹？
Do they intersect in any sort of way or like are all these things kind of like on their own island as far as like impact? I would say like it's a little bit of both. You know, they, I think we found in making the series that they, they led into each other really well, you know, we have an episode about a very famous. sports game that I think the sounds of which you will recognize. And, you know, the way that story ends with a boom shockalaka, shall we say, you know, had us starting to talk about, interestingly enough, just joysticks and the ways
它们是否以某种方式交叉，或者这些东西在影响方面是否各自为政？我会说两者都有。你知道，我想我们在制作这个系列时发现，它们彼此衔接得非常好。你知道，我们有一集是关于一个非常著名的体育游戏，我想你会认出它的声音。而且，那个故事以“Boomshakalaka”结尾的方式，我们开始谈论，有趣的是，仅仅是操纵杆和我们控制这些游戏的方式。
that we control these games. And that leads into a story, for instance, about the hardware that we use to control these games and how that hardware has itself influenced all these other parts of the world that They're not specifically or exclusively about gaming. Is that Roman, would you say that's fair? It's not serialized, but it's... You can listen to each episode on its own, but because the world is so connected, you know, like they kind of talk to each other, and it was becoming clear as we were putting them together,
这引出了一个故事，例如，关于我们用来控制这些游戏的硬件，以及该硬件本身如何影响了世界上所有其他部分，它们并非专门或仅仅关于游戏。罗曼，你会说这公平吗？它不是连续剧，但它是……你可以单独听每一集，但因为世界是如此紧密相连，你知道，它们有点在互相交谈，当我们把它们放在一起时，这一点变得很清楚，
like, oh, this is the right order to speak, you know, to speak about the men, you know, just because it, you know, like it set up those connections kind of nicely. Right. Like, you're talking about controllers. Like, I think before video games, people used to have to fly planes. by pulling these different ropes. Yeah. And then they saw the joysticks and they were like, you know, this could make flying a lot easier.
哦，这是谈论它们的正确顺序，你知道，只是因为它们很好地建立了那些联系。对。就像，你在谈论控制器。我想在电子游戏出现之前，人们过去常常不得不通过拉动这些不同的绳子来驾驶飞机。是的。然后他们看到了操纵杆，他们就像，你知道，这可以让飞行变得容易得多。
It's interesting that you picked. Stay tuned. Episode two, you're going to have the full story because we trace. Emery, like, traces the whole, like, evolution of a joystick part of the plane is involved. You know, war games are involved. Well, I was going to say, it's interesting that airplanes was the thing that you pegged there because I was just thinking based on, using a video game controller and like playing games
有趣的是你选择了这个。敬请期待。第二集，你将听到完整的故事，因为我们追踪了……埃默里（Amory）追踪了整个演变过程，飞机的操纵杆部分涉及其中。你知道，战争游戏也涉及其中。嗯，我正想说，有趣的是飞机是你提到的东西，因为我刚才在想，基于使用电子游戏控制器和玩游戏，
where you have to fly planes or like you know flight simulator or even like you know the Rogue Squadron the Star Wars flying game I kind of think I could fly a plane
你必须驾驶飞机，或者像飞行模拟器，甚至像《侠盗中队》（Rogue Squadron）那样的《星球大战》飞行游戏，我有点觉得我可以驾驶飞机。
I kind of think I could just do it having never tried it Matt have I ever told you the story of me flying a plane I think you have but you have to tell you have to say it now I was in Wisconsin
我有点觉得我可以直接做到，虽然从来没试过。马特，我有没有给你讲过我驾驶飞机的故事？我想你有，但你现在必须讲出来。我在威斯康星州，
and they have those like you know like roadside like get in an airplane that a farmer owns and he'll take you on a quick... I mean, I've never seen that myself, but I understand. If you go deep enough into Wisconsin,
他们有那些，你知道，路边的，进入一架农民拥有的飞机，他会带你进行一次快速的……我的意思是，我自己从来没见过，但我明白。如果你深入威斯康星州，
there's like, you know, the guys who have crop dusters and they're like, you know, 20 bucks for a ride. So I got into one of these planes and was like flying around. And the guy was like, do you want to fly the plane? And I was like, yes.
有那些拥有农作物喷洒机的人，他们会说，20 美元一次飞行。所以我上了其中一架飞机，就像在四处飞行。那个人问，你想驾驶飞机吗？我说，是的。
And so he let me fly the plane. And then he was like, hey, you're pretty good at this. Crazy thing to live. learn while letting somebody else fly a plane. And I was like, yeah, I've played a lot of Microsoft Flight Simulator. And he's like, yeah, it's kind of the same thing. I mean, those Microsoft Flight Simulator, like, folks are for real.
于是他让我驾驶飞机。然后他说，嘿，你在这方面做得不错。活着学到东西真是疯狂，同时让别人驾驶飞机。我说，是的，我玩过很多《微软飞行模拟器》。他说，是的，这有点像同一回事。我的意思是，那些《微软飞行模拟器》的玩家是认真的。
Yeah. That's, that's very, it's close to the real deal. Oh, yeah, with like a full rig. Yeah, yeah, that's tough. The full rig. I hear, I will say, as much as we like flying planes with sort of like game input, I've heard that game controllers are really bad at submarines.
是的。那非常接近真实情况。哦，是的，有完整的装备。是的，是的，那很难。完整的装备。我听说，我会说，尽管我们喜欢用某种游戏输入来驾驶飞机，但我听说游戏控制器在潜水艇上真的很糟糕。
Yeah, I heard something about that too, actually. I can't remember what it was, but I sort of do remember some story I think if I'm remembering the details correctly, a submarine was involved. I'm not sure it was the controller's fault in that situation. It certainly wasn't an airtight
是的，我其实也听说过这件事。我不记得是什么了，但我确实记得一些故事，我想如果我没记错细节的话，涉及了一艘潜水艇。我不确定在那情况下是控制器的错。那肯定不是一个没有逃生出口的气密容器。
vessel with no escape. Yeah. Couldn't have been the reason. There might have been some other science there at all. Yeah, yeah. But it is fascinating and And I love the story that we do about controllers because, and there's a couple of other stories that we have in the series that talk about this too.
是的。不可能是原因。那里可能还有其他科学道理。是的，是的。但这很迷人，我喜欢我们关于控制器的故事，因为，而且我们在系列中还有其他几个故事也谈到了这一点。
And I think Roman said this earlier, these things are talking to each other, right? Like, you have this piece of hardware that's really created for an actual massive mechanical machine that people use to traverse the real world. And that inspires then a digital world. And then that then again goes back and inspires the real world. And I think that's the thing that's really fascinated us when working on this series. That's really cool. Was there anything, I mean, I guess without spoiling any sort of particular story?
我想罗曼之前说过，这些东西在互相交谈，对吧？就像，你拥有这件硬件，它是真正为人们用来穿越现实世界的巨大机械机器而创造的。然后这激发了一个数字世界。然后这又回到并激发了现实世界。我认为这就是在制作这个系列时真正让我们着迷的事情。这真的很酷。有没有什么，我的意思是，我想在不剧透任何特定故事的情况下？
No, I mean, just tell us the top five moments of your upcoming series. Just like, just give us all. I mean, Heather, you sound like you already heard the second episode. So, you know, I don't know. I think somebody leaked it. I don't know. I guess, yeah, was anything in particular, like, particularly revelatory to you? Like, where you, like, upon learning something, you just,
不，我的意思是，告诉我们你即将推出的系列的前五个时刻。就像，把一切都告诉我们。我的意思是，希瑟，你听起来好像已经听过第二集了。所以，你知道，我不知道。我想有人泄露了它。我不知道。我想是的，有什么特别的东西，特别让你大开眼界吗？就像，在学习了一些东西之后，你只是
like never would have even considered like this, like, you know, like a video game being that impactful in the modern sort of world at all. Hmm. Wow. Okay. Well, there's a lot for me. I mean, I thought that the, I mean, what I loved about the joystick one since we, since we're talking about it is, you know, I cover design a lot.
从来没有考虑过电子游戏在现代世界中会有如此大的影响力。嗯。哇。好吧。对我来说有很多。我的意思是，我认为，我的意思是，我喜欢操纵杆的那一集，因为我们正在谈论它，你知道，我经常报道设计。
And so I think about the principles of design. And there's a, there's this concept of affordance, like what a device, you know, kind of telegraphs what you're supposed to do with it just by looking. at it, essentially. And so a joystick has an extremely just grocable affordance. Like, you know that when you want to go up, you push up. When you want to go down, you push down. And so there's that sort of thing. And then, you know, in the world of flat screen, touch screen games, you know, a flat screen has no affordance. Like, you can do anything with a screen. And it becomes, like, less fun to me, you know, like in many ways. And so there's things like that's,
所以我思考设计的原则。有一个概念叫“可供性”（affordance），就像一个设备，你知道，仅仅通过看它，就能传达出你应该用它做什么。所以操纵杆有一种极其容易理解的可供性。就像，你知道当你想要向上时，你向上推。当你想要向下时，你向下推。所以有那种东西。然后，你知道，在平板屏幕、触摸屏游戏的世界里，你知道，平板屏幕没有可供性。就像，你可以用屏幕做任何事情。对我来说，它变得不那么有趣了，你知道，在很多方面。所以有这样的事情，
like the principles of design that we were able to drill down on that, even though I've done a show about design for 15 years, like, I've never really had a good example to describe that to an audience, you know, like, and so when we were talking about it in editing and it was being reported out by Amory, like, you know, like we were able to discuss this and, you know, bring, so it's like, it's just like what was fascinating to me was how fundamental both like, you know, story and thought and theory and design all is, is part of all video games. And it should be obvious because, you know, video games, because, I mean, they are. completely designed from the ground up. There's no part of it that you're like, there is
就像我们能够深入研究的设计原则，尽管我已经做了 15 年关于设计的节目，但我从来没有一个好的例子来向听众描述这一点，你知道，所以当我们谈论它时，在编辑过程中，它是由埃默里报道出来的，就像，我们能够讨论这一点，并带来，所以对我来说迷人的是，故事、思想、理论和设计在所有电子游戏中是多么基础。这应该是显而易见的，因为，电子游戏，因为，我的意思是，它们是
the earth that I'm going to build on and therefore I have to deal with the earth. The earth is created by somebody's mind. The air is created by somebody's mind. And so everything is thought of. And because of that, there's so many avenues to explore because everyone made a decision about every pixel inside of a video game. Yeah. And that is really, that was just like lit me up in sort of every story in so many ways. Because it just is like, there's like super smart people making decisions and thinking about things. And you just, and what's so great about it in this 99% invisible part of video games is you don't necessarily have to feel the author. You just feel immersed. And that means that they're doing a good job in a lot of ways. This is why I particularly
完全从零开始设计的。没有哪一部分你会说，这是我要在其上建造的地球，因此我必须处理地球。地球是由某人的思想创造的。空气是由某人的思想创造的。所以一切都是经过深思熟虑的。正因为如此，有太多的途径可以探索，因为每个人都对电子游戏中的每一个像素做出了决定。是的。这真的，这只是在很多方面点亮了我，在某种意义上的每一个故事中。因为它就像，有超级聪明的人在做决定和思考事情。而你只是，在这个《99% 隐形》的电子游戏部分中，最棒的是你不一定非要感觉到作者。你只是感到沉浸其中。这意味着他们在很多方面做得很好。这就是为什么我特别
enjoy animation over live action is because there's so few accidents in animation. Like so much of it is just curated choices of design and intent. And that's also a lot of video games. Although now there's a lot of emergent play that isn't particularly the designed purpose of the game. Right. And that sort of stuff will, like, float to the surface. I had a side question, which is you talking about the,
喜欢动画胜过真人表演，因为动画中几乎没有意外。就像其中很多只是设计和意图的精心选择。这也是很多电子游戏的情况。虽然现在有很多突发性的游戏玩法，并不是游戏设计的目的。对。那种东西会浮出水面。我有一个附带问题，就是你谈论的，
looking at an object and knowing what its purpose is. And I think this is probably maybe something you've talked about on your podcast before, but if it isn't, I'm super curious. what is what do you think are like what is the most how do I put this what's an object that you think is very poorly not a touchscreen but that you look at it and you don't know what it's supposed to do and it's supposed to do one thing for example when I look at a carrot peeler I am absolutely not thinking that's so that I can scrape it on a carrot I was going
看着一个物体并知道它的用途。我想这可能是你在播客中谈论过的事情，但如果不是，我非常好奇。你认为什么是，我该怎么说，你认为什么物体是非常糟糕的，不是触摸屏，但你看着它，你不知道它应该做什么，而它应该只做一件事。例如，当我看着削皮器时，我绝对不会想到那是为了让我可以在胡萝卜上刮它。我正要
to say pickle picker upper so like I feel like we're in the same headspace somehow. You know those things where you like, you got to like... Like it's a tongue? Yeah. It's sort of like, it looks like a syringe on the back end and on the front end. It looks like one of those claws in the gaming, in the actual... You know what I'm saying?
说“泡菜夹子”。所以我感觉我们不知何故处于同一个频道。你知道那些东西，你必须……就像它是一个舌头？是的。它看起来像后端的注射器，在前端。它看起来像游戏中的那些爪子，在实际的……你知道我在说什么吗？
I actually didn't know that that was what that was. Today we learned... I thought that was for like a turkey. I've seen that in a kitchen and I didn't know. I'll also say... Like scratching her back with it. Picking my pickles. I also think, and this is not because our show is for and made by stupid people.
我其实不知道那是什么。今天我们学到了……我以为那是给火鸡用的。我在厨房里见过那个，我不知道。我还要说……就像用它抓背一样。捡我的泡菜。我也认为，这不是因为我们的节目是为笨人制作的。
Toilets are not, like, they don't necessarily say what they are. You wouldn't necessarily know that you have to do that. Right, because you wouldn't be like, oh, I should go over there and empty into the water. Like, you would look at it and you would think, is this a kind of bathing apparatus? Do I put my foot in here to clean it? Or you see water, and you would, if you had not, if you would just be, I'm going to drink this. Yeah. I mean, my cat thinks that.
马桶不是，它们不一定说明它们是什么。你不一定知道你必须那样做。对，因为你不会说，哦，我应该去那里排泄到水里。就像，你会看着它，你会想，这是一种沐浴器具吗？我把脚放进去清洗吗？或者你看到水，如果你没有，如果你只是，我要喝这个。是的。我的猫是这么想的。
My cat thinks that. Yeah, of course. Yeah, absolutely. Roman is there. If the toilet has 40 buttons on it, it's, then it gets really dangerous. And you know I'm going to push all of them so I can learn exactly what the buttons do and then. And then be horrified by the results. Every now and then.
我的猫是这么想的。是的，当然。是的，绝对。罗曼在那里。如果马桶上有 40 个按钮，那么它就变得非常危险了。而且你知道我会按下所有这些按钮，这样我就可以确切地知道按钮是做什么的，然后。然后被结果吓坏了。偶尔。
Just like the elevator. Yep. Yep. I think the sort of plurality of smart devices have terrible affordance and you don't know how to use them. and you have to read, you know, like, instructions on how to get them. And one of the things that makes things, I mean, like, I would argue not to disagree greatly with the carrot peeler thing, if you had a carrot peeler, I think you'd quickly learn that it peeled. You know, like, you would see it and go, like, here's what I'm handy.
就像电梯一样。是的。是的。我认为多种智能设备具有糟糕的可供性，你不知道如何使用它们。你必须阅读，你知道，关于如何获得它们的说明。我认为让事情变得，我的意思是，我会争辩说，不要与削皮器的事情有太大分歧，如果你有一个削皮器，我想你会很快学会它能削皮。你知道，你会看到它并说，这是我方便的地方。
One way or the other. One way and the other. But, like, I like to think about this as like, you know, you know, when you, you know, I think everyone's had this experience when you've lived in a house for maybe 20 years, and you still don't know which knob goes to which burner on your stove? Yes. That's a type of weird, bad design that is like, it's like you shouldn't have to think about it. Or like if you have a bank of light switches and you have some kind of mnemonic as to which socket it goes to.
一种方式或另一种方式。一种方式和另一种方式。但是，我喜欢这样想，你知道，你知道，当你，你知道，我想每个人都有过这种经历，当你住在一所房子里大约 20 年，你仍然不知道哪个旋钮对应你炉子上的哪个燃烧器？是的。那是一种奇怪的、糟糕的设计，就像你不应该去想它。或者如果你有一排电灯开关，你有一种助记符来知道它对应哪个插座。
Like those represent, you know, design fails. And I think a lot of us take those things on as like, I'm so dumb. I can't remember what light switch goes to which socket. But really those are bad design decisions. And they don't represent, you know, they don't sort of like exhibit good design that would sort of like you would normally have to set that up so you wouldn't get confused. And that's the way to do that. So would you say that in terms of video game design and then real world design that your interests lie in more skeuomorphic design choices? Or are you, do you find that trying to translate like looking at an icon for a tape recorder on a screen doesn't tell you the story that you are.
那些代表，你知道，设计失败。我认为我们很多人认为那些事情是，我很笨。我不记得哪个电灯开关对应哪个插座。但实际上那些是糟糕的设计决定。它们不代表，你知道，它们不展示好的设计，通常你必须设置好它，这样你就不会感到困惑。这就是那样做的方法。那么你会说，在电子游戏设计和现实世界设计方面，你的兴趣在于更拟物化的设计选择吗？或者你发现，试图翻译，比如看着屏幕上的录音机图标，并不能告诉你故事，你
supposed to push that button in order to make the recording start, because also you have dissociated so much from what a tape recorder is? Like, how would you, do you have a way to make game design better? Yeah. I honestly don't. But I mean, I can't tell you, like, you know, I think these sort of, you know, these kind of things like skeuomorphisms that sort of lead people because they, because you know the real world analog and therefore you know how to do them inside of a digital space you know they have
应该按下那个按钮才能开始录音，因为你也已经与录音机是什么脱节了？就像，你会怎么做，你有办法让游戏设计变得更好吗？是的。我真的没有。但我的意思是，我不能告诉你，就像，你知道，我认为这些，你知道，这些东西，比如拟物化，引导人们，因为他们知道现实世界的模拟，因此你知道如何在数字空间内做它们，你知道它们有
their role especially during the transitional phase of of getting used to a digital space but i think at this point um there is like there's no point in putting like an analog you know real to real in front of my kid on icon and and have them have that meek sense to them so like that i think that design language you know just evolve is in changes over time for sure and maybe maybe this is a different kind of thing when we're talking about design, but I, one thing that I'm amazed at, you know,
它们的作用，特别是在习惯数字空间的过渡阶段，但我认为在这一点上，嗯，没有意义把一个模拟的，你知道，卷盘放在我孩子面前的图标上，让他们理解这一点，所以我想那种设计语言，你知道，只是随着时间的推移而演变和改变，当然，也许这在谈论设计时是另一回事，但我，有一件事让我感到惊讶，你知道，
I'm, I'm, uh, 45, right? So like I, the first games that I played were arcade games and Nintendo games. And I remember games that were, they took forever in so long to figure out how to use how to like move the player,
我，我，45 岁，对吧？所以我，我玩的第一批游戏是街机游戏和任天堂游戏。我记得那些游戏，它们花了很长时间才弄清楚如何使用，如何移动玩家，
how to move the sprite, whatever. And just like, um, you know, I think of a game like, well, this is a new example,
如何移动精灵，等等。就像，嗯，你知道，我想起像，嗯，这是一个新的例子，
but like Cuphead, if you know that game. Um, and like that game, I don't think, I don't think, think I've still not made it past the first level of that game. Like, that's a hard, that's a hard game.
但像《茶杯头》（Cuphead），如果你知道那个游戏。嗯，那个游戏，我不认为，我不认为我还没有通过那个游戏的第一关。就像，那是一个很难的游戏。
Yeah. But it's sort of, I feel like it's calling back to some of those games where you, you just really, it didn't sort of push you forward. The game didn't pull you forward in the way the games do now, where like, you're immediately immersed in the space that you're playing in. And you're just getting these directives one at a time, like, like, press X to pick up the gun. You know what I mean?
是的。但它有点，我觉得它在回溯到那些游戏，你，你真的，它没有推动你前进。游戏没有像现在这样把你拉向前方，就像，你立即沉浸在你玩的游戏空间中。你只是一个接一个地得到这些指令，就像，按下 X 键捡起枪。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, there's a, there's a way in which the game is communicating with you as a player. that is, I feel much better now than it used to be, where they used to be kind of like esoteric and hard to get into you in some ways. And now it's like, it's kind of dummy proof some of the way that the games communicate with you as you like move into the environment, if that makes sense.
就像，游戏作为玩家与你交流的方式。我觉得现在比过去好多了，过去它们在某些方面有点深奥，很难进入。而现在，它有点像傻瓜证明，游戏在你进入环境时与你交流的方式，如果这有意义的话。
Sorry. I was going to say so much literacy for video games in general comes from your, like, predetermined knowledge of video. You have to like, I don't think somebody could pick up like the last of us two. for example, having never played a video game before and be like, this is easy to me
抱歉。我正想说，电子游戏的很多素养来自于你，比如，对视频的预定知识。你必须，我不认为有人可以拿起像《最后生还者 2》这样的游戏，例如，从来没有玩过电子游戏，然后说，这对我来说很容易，
because there's so many things you sort of do have to know that the left joystick moves your person and then the right joystick moves your field of vision. And that's like you're sort of learning to sort of pat your head and rub your tummy at the same time kind of with some of these things. Totally. Yeah, but like if you know how to play a video game,
因为有很多东西你确实必须知道，左操纵杆移动你的人，然后右操纵杆移动你的视野。这就像你正在学习一边拍头一边揉肚子，同时处理其中一些事情。完全正确。是的，但如果你知道怎么玩电子游戏，
chances are you're going to know how to play a different video game pretty easily. Yeah. There's also a lot of vestigal stuff that has just become the vocabulary of games Like, for example, there's ammo in barrels And it used to be But I like, if you look at like that
你很有可能很容易就知道怎么玩另一个电子游戏。是的。还有很多残余的东西已经变成了游戏的词汇。例如，桶里有弹药。而且它过去是，但我喜欢，如果你看像那个
Right. That's not real life by the way. That's not how that works in real life. Well, well, but it comes from a time when you're playing these side-scrolling fighting games And there isn't a lot of information on screen And perhaps you're walking through a city And there are trash cans rendered in pixels on the on the screen and so you know oh i can punch those trash cans and when
对。顺便说一句，那不是现实生活。现实生活中不是那样工作的。嗯，嗯，但它来自你玩这些横向卷轴格斗游戏的时代，屏幕上没有太多信息，也许你正走过一个城市，屏幕上有像素渲染的垃圾桶，所以你知道，哦，我可以打那些垃圾桶，当
you punch the trash cans sometimes you'll get a food item that will help your character get their life back and so you'll punch a trash can and a turkey will come out and you'll be like oh i can now i can get better yes but all of that legacy has then gone all the way to effectively last of us part two yeah where you're like smashing shit in the environment to try and find ammunition for your character in a way that you absolutely never would interact with reality no and all of that is sort of um an assumed knowledge on part of the developers that is then you know like you can't like people can watch any movie as their first movie tech like generally yeah it's something that probably shouldn't be your first movie right but you can you you don't
你打垃圾桶时，有时你会得到一个食物，可以帮助你的角色恢复生命，所以你会打一个垃圾桶，一只火鸡会出来，你会说，哦，我可以，现在我可以变得更好。是的，但所有这些遗产都已经一路传到了实际上《最后生还者 2》，在那里你就像在环境中粉碎东西，试图为你的角色找到弹药，以一种你绝对永远不会与现实互动的方式。不，所有这些都是，嗯，开发者的一部分假设知识，然后，你知道，就像你不能，就像人们可以看任何电影作为他们的第一部电影，通常，是的，这是某种可能不应该是你的第一部电影的东西，对吧？但你可以，你不需要，没有很多，狗现在看电影，有所有像狗看《狮子王》并跟随它的视频。我心想，它是怎么？它们在跟随吗？是的，因为它们就像在理解辛巴的弧线。它们绝对在理解辛巴的弧线，
have to like there's not a ton like dogs watch movies now there's all the tic tics of like dogs watching the Lion King and following it. And I'm like, how does it? Are they following it? Yeah, because they're like getting the, they're getting Simba's arc. They are definitely getting Simba's arc
因为当，当，谁是刀疤？刀疤。刀疤在屏幕上。它们会对着刀疤叫，因为他之前伤害了某人。所以狗在跟随它。我心想，狗怎么理解什么是剪辑？它是怎么？就像狮子在那里，然后狮子在……总之，所有这些都是题外话。
because when, when, who's the scar? Scar. Scar's on screen. They'll bark at Scar because he's hurt somebody earlier. So the dog is following it. And I'm like, how does the dog understand what an edit is? How is it? Like the lion is over there and then the lion's over. Anyway, all this is a digression.
要说的是……十只狗里有九只讨厌刀疤。这是真的。这是真的。它们不想。我迷路了。刀疤是一只猫。
to say that... Nine out of ten dogs hate scar. That is true. That is true. They don't want. I got lost. Scar's a cat.
刀疤是一只猫。对。是的，它们都讨厌……狗不喜欢那样。它们讨厌所有的狮子。让我们进入你们对游戏的总体历史。我们从本那里得到了一点。但让我们更深入一点。
Scar's a cat. Right. Yeah, they all hate... Dogs don't like that. They hate all the lions. Let's get into like your histories with gaming in general. We got a little bit of bends there. But let's get into it just a little bit deeper.
你们现在对游戏处于什么位置，我想这是一个很好的切入点？是的，你在《堡垒之夜》里的排名是多少？天哪，勉强，勉强存活五分钟。我的意思是，《堡垒之夜》，我在《堡垒之夜》的经历，《堡垒之夜》是那些游戏之一，我可以，我认为它在匹配方面做得更好了，对吧？就像，我刚开始玩《堡垒之夜》时，也许我也进步了，希望如此，但当我刚开始玩时，就像两分钟的尖叫，然后重新开始。
Where are you guys at with games like today, I guess, is a good jumping off point? Yeah, what's your rank in Fortnite? Man, barely, barely survives five minutes. I mean, Fortnite, my experience in Fortnite, Fortnite's one of those games where I can, I think it's gotten better at matching, right? Like, I used it when I first started playing Fortnite, and maybe I've gotten better too, hopefully, but when I first started playing, it was like two minutes of me screaming and then starting over.
你知道我的意思吗？就像我只是在跑和躲，然后重新开始。嗯，我，我，我会说我投入了，你知道，真的我的，我的游戏，嗯，这些天是关于连接的。我真的很喜欢和，嗯，我在全国各地的好朋友交谈，我，我再也见不到他们了。嗯，你知道，他们有自己的生活。我有我自己的生活。他们，你知道，他们是父母，我是父母。所以我和他们联系的方式之一是我们一起玩游戏，嗯，我们一起学习背景故事，我们，你知道，我们每周花几个小时做这件事。这真的很棒。嗯，
Do you know what I mean? Like, I was just like running and hiding and then starting over. Um, I, I, I will say that I put, you know, really my, my gaming, um, is, is these days about connection. I really like talking to, uh, my good friends across the country who I, who I don't see anymore. Um, you know, they have their own lives. I have my own life. They, you know, their parents, I'm a parent. So one of the ways that I connect with them is we play games together and, um, and we learn the lore together and we, you know, we spend a couple hours every week doing that. And that's really wonderful. Um,
而且，而且它真的，它真的不是关于磨练，而是关于，嗯，互相交谈。而且，你知道，我们基本上进行了小组治疗会议，你知道，当我们经历生活挑战时互相交谈。而且，嗯，我们这些天做的很多事情是一种第二屏幕活动，或者你同时做几件事。而且，嗯，我不知道这是坏还是好。但我只知道，就像我和我的哥们，我们每周都交谈。而且，那，那对我来说很有意义。所以我玩《绝地潜兵》（Hell Divers）。我们刚开始玩《暗黑破坏神 4》。
And, and it's really, it's really less about the grind and more about, um, talking to each other. And, you know, we've basically had group therapy sessions, you know, talking to each other as we've gone through life challenges. And, and, um, a lot of what we do these days is a sort of second screen activity or you're doing a couple of things at the same time. And, and I don't know if that's bad or good. But I just know that like my buddies and I, we talk every week. And that's, that's meaningful to me. And so I play hell diver as I play. We just started playing Diablo 4.
我们玩了像每一部《狙击精英》（Sniper Elite），因为我的一个哥们只是痴迷于狙击，这就是他喜欢做的事情。我玩了《零世代》（Generation Z）。我非常喜欢那个游戏，因为它的制作，就像在那种后世界末日战斗机器人的世界中移动，这是，你知道，这是一个经典的桥段。而且它有效，但我大多只是为了好玩。我的意思是，我们尝试玩更奇怪、更水獭的游戏，但我们有一种分裂。小组的一半人说，我只想开枪。而小组的一半人说，不，让我们用游戏做一些奇怪和有趣的事情。
We played like every sniper elite because one of my buddies is just obsessed with sniping and that's what he loves to do. I played Generation Z. I liked that game a lot because of the crafting and just like moving through that sort of post-apocalyptic fighting robots world, which is, you know, that's a classic trope. and it works, but mostly I just do it for fun. I mean, we've tried to play weirder, otter games, but we have a kind of split. Half of the group is like, I just want to shoot guns. And half of the group is like, no, let's do something weird and interesting with games.
所以有时我们会为此争吵。但通常，对我来说，这只是一个连接的地方，一种连接和发泄的方式。是的。罗曼，我说的对吗，你是一个有点过期的玩家，你会这么说吗？是的，我不知道我是否曾经真正是一个玩家。我的意思是，我有点，我今天不做太多游戏。我有点被动，比如当我列出时玩塔防类游戏。我必须为我的工作听很多音频。
And so sometimes we fight about that. But generally, for me, it's just a place to connect and a way to connect and blow off steam. Yeah. And Roman, am I correct, you're a bit of a lapsed gamer, would you say? Yeah, I don't know if I was ever really a gamer as such. I mean, I kind of, I don't do much gaming today. I kind of do passive, like, tower defense type games when I'm listed. I have to listen to a lot of audio for my job.
是的。所以我需要一些不需要很好时机的东西，你知道，这是我可以在做其他事情时做的事情。所以我喜欢塔防游戏。而且我在 Oculus 上玩一些健身游戏，因为我喜欢拳击之类的东西。哦，酷。我因为拳击而伤了背，真的当我打东西时，比如坚硬的东西。哦，当然。打了一个垃圾桶？
Yeah. And so I need something that doesn't really require good timing, you know, that is something I can do while I'm doing something else. And so I love tower defense games. And I play some fitness games like on an Oculus because I like to box and stuff like this. Oh, cool. And I injured my back boxing for real when I punched stuff, like solid things. Oh, sure. Did a trash can?
你是在试图在垃圾桶里找火鸡吗？不，我希望。但到处都没有火鸡。我试过了。再等几个月。到处都会有火鸡。那是真的。那是真的。
Were you trying to find a turkey in a trash can? No, I wish. But there are no turkeys anywhere. I've tried. Just wait a couple months. There's going to be turkeys everywhere. That's true. That's true.
所以我喜欢像《超自然》（Supernatural）。我喜欢像做那样的事情。对我来说很有趣。但我的历史很奇怪。你知道，我在 90 年代参与了游戏中最早的语音聊天开发。哇。所以我有一个大学同学，他开发了这个叫 Roger Wilco 的应用程序。这是一个独立的应用程序，在你的《博德之门》或你的《毁灭战士》或你的《部落》后面。
So I love like supernatural. I love like doing stuff like that. It's pretty fun for me. But my history is strange. You know, I was involved in the development of some of the first voice chat in gaming in the 90s. Wow. And so I had a friend who I went to college with, and he developed this app called Roger Wilco. It was a standalone application that was behind your Baldur's Gate or your Doom or your Tribes.
它在 28.8 调制解调器上运行。它非常干净且制作精美。我是该公司的第一个 QA 测试员。所以我玩了很多像那样的早期多人游戏。事实上，卖掉它，很有趣，就像卖掉那家公司支付了我在公共广播的三年实习费用，这引导我成为一名播客。哇。哇。哇。
And it ran on a 28-8 modem. It was super clean and beautifully done. And I was the first QA tester for the company. And so I played a lot of early multiplayer games like that. And in fact, selling that, it was funny, it was like selling that company is what paid for my three-year internship in public radio that led me into being a podcast. Wow. Wow. Wow.
谈谈学习背景故事。酷。所以，是的。所以很早，所以我过去测试游戏。所以我玩了像几个小时又几个小时的游戏，Roger Wilco 在下面运行，只是为了看看它是否有效，如果，你知道，所有的技术是否有效。所以这就是我所做的，你知道，像 90 年代中期、后期，是的。你，从那个时候起，你还记得一个游戏，你当时觉得，这个？就像，它感觉不像工作，那种你觉得，我实际上很享受这一个。
Talk about learning the lore. Cool. So, yeah. So early, so I used to test games. So I played games like hours and hours with Roger Wilco running underneath it just to see if it works and if, you know, all the technology works. And so that's what I did for, you know, like mid, late 90s, yeah. Do you, from that time, do you remember a game that you were like, this? Like, it didn't feel like work, kind of, that you were like, I'm actually enjoying this one.
是《部落》（Tribes）。我是《部落》叛徒模组中的狙击手，我可以进入一个服务器，我可以清理它，因为我只是杀戮。我只是歼灭，人们一看到我的名字出现就离开了。我开始不得不，像，用不同的名字进来，这样他们就会玩得更久。但是，是的，如果有人知道《部落》，那会。是我的游戏。我会进入那个超越。我喜欢你的把手。门德尔，我是一个遗传学，博士生，所以我叫门德尔。如果你，如果你这么擅长狙击，而且你不以门德尔的身份出现，我喜欢服务器上的那一刻，当人们
It's tribes. I was a sniper in the renegade mod of tribes, and I could come on to a server, and I could clear it because I just killed. I would just annihilate, and people would just leave as soon as they saw my name show up. And I began to have to, like, come in with different names so that they would play longer. But, yeah, if anyone knows tribes, that would. was like, that was totally my game. I would get into that one beyond. I love your handle. Mendel, I was a genetics, a Ph.D. student, so I went by Mendel. If you're, if you're this good at sniping and you don't come on as Mendel, I love the moment on a server when people
就像，哦该死，树莓幽灵（Raspberry Ghost）是门德尔。树莓幽灵是门德尔。我过去常常让很多人感到沮丧。每个人，对不起，作弊之类的。这真的就像，我只是擅长。我只是在这方面很棒，伙计们。你可以是门德尔。我想，因为我也，我喜欢拳击。我也是一名拳击手。
are like, oh shit, Raspberry Ghost is Mendel. Raspberry Ghost is Mendel. I used to frustrate a lot. Everyone, excuse me, of cheating and stuff like this. It was really like, I'm just good. I'm just great at this guys. You could be Mendel. I want to, because I also, I love to box. I'm also a boxer.
你选择的 VR 拳击应用程序是什么？我做《超自然》。我喜欢那个，因为我喜欢，我喜欢音乐。它基本上是，它不是，而且我已经做了，什么是为了什么，我不知道。还有另一个实际上是电子游戏的游戏。像那样，当你有一个对手时。我也玩过那个，它让我筋疲力尽。那太棒了。
What is your VR boxing app of choice? I do Supernatural. I like that one because I like the, I like the music. It's basically, it's not, and I've done, what is the fight for, I don't know. There's another one that's actually a video game game. like that when you have an opponent. I've played that one too, and it wears me out. That's great.
它们主要是像健身游戏。它们不像，或者健身应用程序。它们不像只是一个拳击游戏那么多。对。是的。是的。但它们可能是游戏化的，对吧？这是世界如何改变的另一个例子，或者电子游戏世界
And they're mainly like fitness games. They're not so much like, or fitness apps. They're not so much just like a boxing game so much. Right. Yeah. Yeah. But they're probably gamified, right? Which is another example of how the world changes or the video game world
改变了另一个，世界的其余部分，对吧？是的。当然。是的。不，它真的有帮助。它确实非常激励人，当然。而且，你知道，教你，你知道，模式之类的东西。而且它很好。
changes the other, the rest of the world, right? Yeah. For sure. Yeah. No, it really helped. It really is motivating for, for sure. And, you know, teaches you know, patterns and stuff like that. And it's good.
改变了彼此，改变了世界其他地方，对吧？是的，当然。不，这真的很有帮助。这确实非常鼓舞人心。而且，你知道，它教会了你模式之类的东西。这很好。
It mainly just sort of gets me. moving. I don't quite have the constitution to sit and play a game anymore. I kind of, I just like, that's just not how I'm wired anymore. Even when I watch TV, I walk on a treadmill most the time. And so, um, uh, so fitness gaming is sort of my, my version of just like moving and playing games at the same time. The, the, to the tower defense aspect of, uh, of your gaming, though, I don't play a lot of those games, though, but like, I could see like a game like that being a good second thing you're doing while like, you know, listening to, uh, of your game. you know, I have edited my own voice for a long time too.
它主要是让我动起来。我现在的体质已经不太适合坐着玩游戏了。我那种……怎么说呢，我的思维方式已经变了。即使看电视时，我大部分时间也在跑步机上走。所以，嗯，健身游戏算是我同时运动和玩游戏的一种方式。不过，关于你提到的塔防类游戏，虽然我玩得不多，但我能想象，当你一边做别的事，比如听东西时，玩那种游戏会很合适。你知道，我也剪辑自己的声音很久了。
So like, to whatever is getting me focused on not hearing my own voice and, you know, how horrible I sound when I speak, I'll enjoy another activity as well. But I get distracted because the things, the games that I pick are going to be like, like, like, Hollow Night's Silk Song or like Eldon Ring or something where I have to be so focused on the actions of what's going on. But like a tower defense thing, it's like a set it and forget it type of thing. What's the appeal for you there? Yeah. I mean, it's basically that.
所以，为了让自己专注于别的事情，不去听自己的声音，也不去想我说话时声音有多难听，我也会享受其他活动。但我很容易分心，因为我选的游戏通常是像《空洞骑士：丝之歌》或《艾尔登法环》这类需要高度集中注意力的游戏。但塔防游戏就像是那种“设置好就不用管”的类型。你觉得它的吸引力在哪里？是的，基本上就是这样。
It's like you can, there's a little bit of timing involved usually as it gets at the upper levels or whatever. But like your precise sort of, you know, Metroid style timing is not required. And so it's just sort of like you have to kind of be a present. And I just find that it actually kind of helps me focus because I can drift listening. I have to listen to hours and hours of people talking, like, in terms of, like, raw tape of people talking. I listen to a ton of podcasts, and I listen to a lot of books on tape, in quotes, for my job to prepare for interviews. And I used to do this when I worked at WBUR, sorry, WBUR. I worked at WBZ in Chicago, and I used to sit at my desk, and one of my jobs was listening to audio documentaries all day long.
就像你可以……通常在高难度关卡时需要一点时机把握，但不需要像《银河战士》那种精确的操作。所以你只需要保持专注。我发现这实际上有助于我集中注意力，因为我可以一边听一边走神。我必须听几个小时甚至更久的人们谈话，比如原始录音。为了准备采访，我的工作需要听大量的播客和有声书。我以前在WBUR工作时也这样做过，抱歉，是WBUR。我在芝加哥的WBZ工作时，经常坐在办公桌前，我的工作之一就是整天听音频纪录片。
And I sit at my desk to play Solitaire, and people would walk by, and, like, I actually had, like, a man. manager sort of make fun of me, like complain that I was playing a game all day instead of doing my job. Wow. And it was like, I need this to do my job. Like, I am listening to this stuff. And if I was just listening, I would doze off. I would not, I would lose focus.
我坐在桌前玩纸牌游戏，人们走过时，甚至有位经理嘲笑我，抱怨我整天玩游戏而不是在工作。哇。但我当时想，我需要这样做才能完成工作。我在听这些内容，如果只是干听，我会打瞌睡，会失去专注力。
And I, so I started using games then to sort of like to sort of keep my ears open, actually. I've only ever been able to play video games at one job. I guess if you don't count this one, but we don't play video games when we're doing this. We could. We should. It'd be more interesting for us probably. are constantly asking us to do the thing that you're saying right now, which is why don't you guys live stream your games? And it's, for me, it's that speaking while gaming is almost
所以我开始用游戏来保持清醒。我只在这一份工作中玩过电子游戏。如果这不算的话，但我们做节目时并不玩游戏。我们可以玩，也应该玩，那样可能更有趣。听众经常要求我们做你刚才说的那种事，也就是“你们为什么不直播玩游戏呢？”对我来说，边玩游戏边说话几乎是……
impossible. Yeah. Like, I can't, I can't play a guitar and talk. Well, I can't play a guitar. And just another avenue of perception, too. I just don't need it. Terrible. But I worked at a, I worked at a restaurant in their office taking reservations. And so it was a nice Michelin Star Restaurant in town. I'll say it where it was afterward. And I... Burger King.
不可能的。是的。就像我没法一边弹吉他一边说话。好吧，我根本不会弹吉他。那只是另一种感知途径，我不需要它。太糟糕了。但我曾在一家餐厅的办公室负责预订工作。那是一家米其林星级餐厅，我稍后会说出它的名字。我……汉堡王。
It was at Burger King. And I had just... Burger time. Yeah, I was with... The chef's name, I think, is Peter Pickle or something. Peter Pickle. But I would bring my switch to work. And, like, I was like, I'm really testing the limits of what I'm allowed to do.
是在汉堡王。我当时……汉堡时间。是的，我和……主厨的名字好像叫彼得·皮克尔还是什么的。彼得·皮克尔。但我会带Switch去上班，我当时觉得，我真的在测试我能做的事情的底线。
do here, I think, because this, I'm very obviously playing a video game, but my job is to answer the phone and put in a reservation on a computer if somebody calls to make the reservation, right? And then I'm calling people confirming reservations, but apart from that, I'm sitting at a desk for hours. There's not another facet to that job. So I was like, I have to do something, or I'm just never going to come back here. It's just, then you're just trapped, not doing it.
我想，因为我显然在玩电子游戏，但我的工作是接电话，如果有人打电话预订，我就在电脑上输入预订信息，对吧？然后我还要打电话给别人确认预订，但除此之外，我得在桌前坐好几个小时。那份工作没有其他内容了。所以我当时想，我必须做点什么，否则我永远不会再来这里了。不然你就只是被困在那里，什么都不做。
anything. And so I started to bring my switch to work. And also, I'm working at night, right? The restaurant closes at 11. So from like 9 to like 11 o'clock, nobody's calling to make a dinner reservation. I'm just chilling and getting paid and playing breath of the wild. It was like, actually, I think about that time a lot. I had less going for me. You had it good. But that was, that was good. That was really, really nice. Isn't it funny how memories like that can just, of playing games can just be so powerful and sort of like remind you of a time in your life. I feel like that's, I don't know. I just, like, when you were describing that, I was, I know exactly what you mean, where
所以我开始带Switch去上班。而且我是在晚上工作，对吧？餐厅11点关门。所以从9点到11点，没人会打电话来预订晚餐。我就在那儿放松，拿着工资玩《荒野之息》。我经常想起那段时光。我当时没什么追求。你那时过得真不错。但那确实很好，真的非常棒。你不觉得像那样玩游戏的记忆很神奇吗？它们能如此强烈地提醒你生命中的某段时光。我觉得……我不知道。当你描述那个场景时，我完全明白你的意思，就是……
you were like, maybe it wasn't the best job or the best situation, but like 9 p.m. to 11 p.m., man, you were free to, you know, do your thing. I was just hanging out, but I couldn't leave in case somebody called, right? They couldn't call me off because what if somebody does call? Dutt did want to call or something. They couldn't, they can't have somebody else doing that. Yeah.
你当时可能不是在最好的工作或最好的处境中，但晚上9点到11点，伙计，你是自由的，可以做你想做的事。我只是在那儿闲逛，但又不能离开，以防有人打电话，对吧？他们不能让我走，因为万一有人打电话呢？万一有人想预订什么的。他们不能让别人做那件事。是的。
They're doing something more important. If you were VR boxing, maybe that would not fly, but I feel like switch. Switch should. Yeah. If I had brought my dance dance revolution rig to the office, probably not a good idea.
他们有更重要的事情要做。如果你在办公室玩VR拳击，那可能行不通，但我觉得Switch应该可以。如果我带了《跳舞机》设备去办公室，那可能不是个好主意。
Are you familiar with the VR game super hot? Yeah. It's a game where you're like John Wick basically like dodging like or you know I guess Neo more like in that you're you're a Keanu Reeves type character in this game and you're like dodging bullets and like throwing knives and stuff that would not be great for yeah right that's a very fun game I played that one for sure it rules it is so so fun um band we do have to talk about this your name on the on the chat right now is battle toads band battlehoods and we did talk about
你熟悉VR游戏《燥热》(Superhot)吗？是的。那是一款让你感觉像约翰·威克，或者说更像尼奥的游戏，你在游戏中扮演基努·里维斯那样的角色，躲避子弹、扔飞刀之类的。那在办公室里可不太好，对吧？那是一款非常有趣的游戏，我肯定玩过，它太棒了，真的非常有趣。嗯，我们要谈谈这个，你现在的聊天名字是“战斗蛤蟆”(Battletoads)粉丝，我们之前谈过……
this a little bit I did ask you who your favorite battle toad is and you did say Zit And that's the only correct answer I think Wart's tough What's the other one? I don't remember what I remember Whipple, right? What's that? Isn't it Wart? Rash. Rash? Rash. I was about to say one of them was Piss and it's not Piss.
这个话题。我问过你最喜欢哪只战斗蛤蟆，你说的是Zit。我想这是唯一正确的答案。Wart很强。另一个叫什么来着？我不记得了，我记得是Whipple，对吧？那是什么？不是叫Wart吗？Rash。Rash？Rash？我刚才差点说其中一个是Piss，但并不是。
If it was Piss, you'd buy it. You'd sort of like, I guess one of them is pissed. You would not buy it because you were the child. They're all skin conditions. And your parents definitely wouldn't buy you a game where it's like Zit and rash and piss.
如果它叫Piss，你肯定会买。我想其中一个确实是Piss。你不会买的，因为你还是个孩子。它们都是皮肤病的名字。你父母绝对不会给你买那种角色叫Zit、Rash和Piss的游戏。
Yeah, Battletoads much more, yeah. They should, this is a free idea to anybody making a video game then. As soon as you name your character piss, I'm buying the game. It doesn't matter what kind of game it is. I'm there. But I was so excited when I was, you know, I've recently discovered the show and have become a listener. So I love what you all do and the joy with which you do it.
是的，战斗蛤蟆好多了。这对于任何制作电子游戏的人来说都是一个免费的点子。只要你把角色命名为Piss，我肯定会买。不管是什么类型的游戏，我都会买。但我当时很兴奋，因为我最近发现了这个节目，并成为了听众。我喜欢你们所做的一切，以及你们做节目时展现出的那种快乐。
And I, but you have like a deep, you got a deep catalog. and I discovered that you have a Battletoads episode, I think, or the show has a Battletoads episode. Yeah, I'll send it to you. I think it's behind a paywall, but I'll get that over to you. Oh, my God. I would love to listen to it because that was one of those games
而且你们的节目库很深。我发现你们有一期关于《战斗蛤蟆》的节目。是的，我会发给你。我想它在付费墙后面，但我会把它弄给你。天哪，我太想听了，因为那是我玩过的游戏之一。
that, again, like, there was a period of, and I should say, like, I tell a lot of people, I think I've said this to Roman, when I was growing up, my parents wouldn't let me have a Nintendo. They wouldn't let me play video games until I was, you know, maybe 12, 14 years old. so I was always I was the kid who would come over to your house and you'd be like hey let's play outside and I'd be like hey man take me to the basement show me the Nintendo and like if you have
再说一次，就像，有一段时间，我应该说，我告诉很多人，我想我跟罗曼说过，我小时候，父母不让我玩任天堂。直到我大概12、14岁，他们才让我玩电子游戏。所以我总是那个去你家做客的孩子，你会说嘿，我们去外面玩吧，而我会说嘿伙计，带我去地下室，给我看看任天堂，如果你有
snacks that's cool and if you want to leave me there that's also cool I just need please I got to have it so your hands gripping tighter and tighter around his neck show me where it is man please but like but Battletoads was one of those early games that I played and and I recently I I guess I was like poking around about this and realized it's it's also like connected to double dragon right like there was a combo version of the game I think there was battle toads versus double dragon where they all teamed up or Battletoads X double dragon yes you're you're not incorrect this is a game fair and and and so like but what what I remember of Battletoads was it was a super hard game oh yeah I was you know I was maybe nine but like it was such a hard game and
零食那很酷，如果你想把我留在那儿也行，我只是需要，拜托，我一定要玩到它，所以你的手紧紧地抓着他的脖子，告诉我它在哪儿，拜托，但是《忍者蛙》是我玩过的早期游戏之一，我最近在研究这个，意识到它也和《双截龙》有关，对吧？我想有一个组合版本，我想是《忍者蛙》对战《双截龙》，他们联手了，或者《忍者蛙》X《双截龙》，是的，你没说错，这是一款游戏，所以，我记得《忍者蛙》是一款超级难的游戏，哦是的，我当时大概九岁，但它确实是一款很难的游戏，而且
it was again one of those games where you you you I never progressed past there was like a there's a level where you're you're like on a surfboard or maybe it's more like it's like you're you're you're jumping over the the the walls and the walls flash for like a half second before they arrive on screen yes and and I just that's one of those games that has like a sense memory for me where I just I I can I can I can remember the you know the Doritas dust on my fingertips and the sweat of like trying to get past that level. And I don't know if I ever did, but I loved that game. That was a great game.
它又是那种你永远无法通关的游戏，有一关你是在冲浪板上，或者更像是你在跳过墙壁，墙壁在出现在屏幕上之前会闪烁半秒钟，是的，那是我有感官记忆的游戏之一，我能记得指尖上的多力多滋粉末，以及试图通过那一关时的汗水。我不知道我是否真的通关了，但我很喜欢那个游戏。那是一款很棒的游戏。
It's funny that talking about your parents not letting you play video games reminds me of a very sort of semi-famous in gaming circles. Far Side comic from the 90s or like maybe it was late 80s where it's a kid playing video games and the parents are daydreaming of a career in video. games and the joke is that'll never happen because like that's what the far side is saying is oh that'll never happen these guys are all idiots and now you can make so much money
有趣的是，谈到你父母不让你玩电子游戏，让我想起了游戏圈里半有名的一件事。90年代或者可能是80年代末的《远见》漫画，讲的是一个孩子在玩电子游戏，父母在幻想他从事电子游戏职业，笑话是那永远不会发生，因为《远见》漫画的意思是，哦，那永远不会发生，这些家伙都是白痴，而现在你可以赚这么多钱
playing video games that the comic doesn't make sense yeah you can like it doesn't the joke doesn't work you can make a lot of money you can affect politics in a very particular way it's all very interesting yeah yeah
玩电子游戏，以至于漫画都没意义了，是的，笑话行不通了，你可以赚很多钱，你可以以一种非常特殊的方式影响政治，这一切都非常有趣，是的，是的
sometimes too interesting. Yeah, it's a little too interesting. Like, actually, everybody calmed down. Stop, actually. Yeah. Well, guys, before we get you out of here, I guess I don't know if this is necessarily spoiling or could spoil, but I have, I guess, another question, just about
有时太有趣了。是的，有点太有趣了。就像，实际上，大家都冷静点。停下，真的。是的。好吧，伙计们，在你们离开之前，我不知道这是否算剧透，或者可能会剧透，但我有一个问题，关于
video games and their impact on society at large. Yeah. Good or bad? One word answer, bye. Just coming on. No, no, I think like I, well, what I would say is, um, so my son, I have twins who are eight years old. My son is eight years old. Uh, he is, uh, he's, he's, he's, he loves Minecraft. Yeah. He loves, um, uh, he, he loves, um, the Harry Potter game. I, I have mixed feelings about, I don't know, I have a mixed, mixed feelings about the creator of Harry Potter, but my son loves that game. Yeah. I, uh, I think that that. I, uh, I think that. I think that. that games like Dungeons and Dragons, for instance, which, you know, inspired a lot of video games, they do teach you to, number one, solve problems. And number two, like, have a safe space to try to
电子游戏及其对整个社会的影响。是的。好还是坏？一个词回答，再见。刚开始。不，不，我想，嗯，我会说的是，嗯，我的儿子，我有八岁的双胞胎。我儿子八岁。呃，他，呃，他，他，他喜欢《我的世界》。是的。他喜欢，嗯，呃，他，他喜欢，嗯，哈利波特游戏。我，我对哈利波特的创作者有复杂的情绪，我不知道，我有复杂的情绪，但我儿子喜欢那个游戏。是的。我，呃，我想那。我，呃，我想那。我想那。像《龙与地下城》这样的游戏，你知道，启发了很多电子游戏，它们确实教会你，第一，解决问题。第二，有一个安全的空间去尝试
solve problems and fail and try again. And I think that they can lead you, especially in the case of things like Minecraft, they can lead you to be really creative, right? I also think that they are You know, I mean, this is going to maybe sound ridiculous to some of your listeners, because, you know, whoever bought the latest, you know, PS5 Pro or whatever. But, like, they are also, like, relatively cheap. Like, you can, you can access games relatively cheaply. And I think having an interactive form of entertainment that you can, that is, you know, relatively democratized, both in terms of playing, but also in terms of building now,
解决问题，失败，然后再试。我认为它们可以引导你，特别是在《我的世界》这类游戏中，它们可以引导你变得非常有创造力，对吧？我也认为它们是，你知道，我的意思是，这对你们的一些听众来说可能听起来很荒谬，因为，你知道，谁买了最新的PS5 Pro之类的。但是，它们也相对便宜。你可以相对便宜地玩到游戏。我认为拥有一种互动的娱乐形式，你知道，相对民主化，无论是在玩方面，还是在现在的构建方面，
like the fact that you can build games more. easily. Um, that's, that's a good thing. Um, I think where it gets problematic is when, um, we, um, you know, I think I, I, when we allow any sort of tech company to, um, to not have any kind of, um, consequences for, you know, whatever, like fomenting hate or, you know, and I think, you know, game companies have gotten better at policing this stuff, I guess. Um, And maybe I shouldn't even use the word policing. I think it's complicated. No, for sure.
事实是你更容易构建游戏。嗯，那是一件好事。嗯，我认为有问题的地方在于，嗯，我们，嗯，你知道，我想我，当我们允许任何科技公司，嗯，对，嗯，任何后果，你知道，无论是什么，比如煽动仇恨，或者，你知道，我认为，你知道，游戏公司在监管这些东西方面做得更好了，我想。嗯，也许我不应该用监管这个词。我认为这很复杂。不，当然。
Yeah. But I think like, you know, it can be addicting to you. And like that's a dangerous zone. And so, you know, limiting your, limiting your time, I think is for me, that's an important thing. But ultimately, it's like so much of the technology we use. It can be a positive thing. It can be a negative thing. It's just a tool and it's a technology.
是的。但我认为，你知道，它可能会让你上瘾。那是一个危险的区域。所以，你知道，限制你的时间，我认为对我来说，那很重要。但归根结底，它就像我们使用的许多技术一样。它可以是积极的，也可以是消极的。它只是一个工具，一种技术。
And we just have to be intentional and careful and thoughtful and caring. in the way that we use it, and in the way that we use it together. Wow. That is the most thoughtful thing ever said on this show. Yeah, truly. Public radio.
我们只需要在我们的使用方式上，以及我们共同使用它的方式上，保持意图、谨慎、深思熟虑和关怀。哇。这是这个节目中说过的最深思熟虑的话。是的，真的。公共广播。
What are you going to do? I don't know. I didn't think one of the frogs was called piss, really. Yeah, exactly. And my favorite battle to the Zit. Thank you. Same show where we're like,
你要做什么？我不知道。我没想到其中一只青蛙叫尿，真的。是的，没错。我最喜欢的忍者蛙是Zit。谢谢。同一个节目，我们就像，
toilets look like you should drink them. But I'm curious, like, Roman, what do you think? I feel like... Oh, I think good. I don't know. I don't really have... I feel exactly the same as you, but I think the dial is more towards good. I also just think that you can't sort of argue that the world be a better or worse place without video games.
厕所看起来你应该喝它们。但我很好奇，罗曼，你怎么看？我觉得……哦，我觉得很好。我不知道。我真的没有……我觉得和你完全一样，但我认为天平更倾向于好的一面。我也只是认为你不能争论世界没有电子游戏会变得更好或更糟。
You just could argue. It's just going to... It would be a completely different world without... Yeah. And that's really the sort of the end of it, you know? Like, it's just like they're a huge part. And I think that in addition to, you know, you mentioning like there actually are, you know, careers in video games as evidenced by like us being on a podcast now is like it kind of trains you to think in ways that, you know, are perfect for the modern world in terms of problem solving and in terms of, you know, just like quick thinking and dexterity and the sort of idea of if then, you know, decisions and complex decisions. And I, you know, I think they're great. I don't know. I have a hard time thinking. I do think that the social. aspect of them that can sort of cause issues is the same social aspect that makes social media
你只是可以争论。它只是会……没有它，世界将完全不同……是的。这真的是结局，你知道吗？就像它们是重要的一部分。我认为除了你提到的，你知道，确实有电子游戏职业，正如我们现在在播客上所证明的那样，它训练你以适合现代世界的方式思考，在解决问题方面，在快速思考和灵活性方面，以及如果……那么……的决策和复杂决策的理念。而且，你知道，我认为它们很棒。我不知道。我很难思考。我确实认为它们的社交方面可能会导致问题，这与社交媒体导致的问题是一样的，
a problem that makes you know tabloids a problem like everything it's yeah when you get a bunch of people together they can get together for nefarious ends as well as you know great ends and so that's just part of it all well guys that was i really enjoyed talking to you guys thank you so much for uh for being here with us today. Why don't you guys plug the show again real quick, and then we'll get you out of here. Sure. The six-part series is called Hidden Levels. It's about how video games affect the world, and it's a co-production of 99% Invisible, which is my podcast, and Endless Thread, which is Ben Brock Johnson's podcast, and it's going to come out wide on October 7th. Yeah, we hope you'll listen. Let us know how much we got wrong. Just kidding.
这使得你知道小报成为一个问题，就像一切一样，是的，当你把一群人聚在一起时，他们可以为了邪恶的目的聚在一起，也可以为了伟大的目的聚在一起，所以这只是其中的一部分。好吧，伙计们，我真的很喜欢和你们聊天，非常感谢你们今天来到这里。你们为什么不快速再宣传一下节目，然后我们就让你们离开。当然。这个六集系列叫《隐藏关卡》。它是关于电子游戏如何影响世界的，这是我的播客《99%隐形》和本·布洛克·约翰逊的播客《无尽线索》的联合制作，它将于10月7日全面发布。是的，我们希望你们会收听。让我们知道我们哪里错了。开个玩笑。
Guys, thanks so much. Yeah, thank you. I really appreciate it. Yeah, thanks, y'all. It was great to be with you. You can find Get Played wherever you get podcasts, and there's a link in the show notes. We'll see you Tuesday for episode one of Hidden Levels. Oh, boom, Shakalaka! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
伙计们，非常感谢。是的，谢谢。我真的很感激。是的，谢谢你们。和你们在一起很棒。你可以在任何获取播客的地方找到《Get Played》，节目说明里有链接。我们周二见，届时将播出《隐藏关卡》的第一集。哦，砰，沙卡拉卡！本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。